thank you very much for the invitation
that's true that I'm the I think really
the only one not only in Germany but on
worldwide being a computer scientist as
a data protection commissioner meanwhile
there there are a few deputies so they
have already some more influence and the
gdpr is quite new only one and a half
months old so there are many open
questions I think even more now for me
then before the application because
otherwise I was able to read and to
understand with my background and now
everything is challenging that because
everybody is reading the gdpr from their
background as well first of all who has
heard nothing of the gdpr yet ok who has
read a little bit within yes ok who is
read everything
I don't believe no it's and I think I
read parts hundred times I'm still
learning so this cannot be the the final
answer but of course at the beginning of
for the debate and you will play an
important role in making true what is
good in the gdpr
and perhaps finding solutions also for
the rest what's very nice to hear
schleswig-holstein pronounced here
already we're in the top north of
Germany you see Berlin there there we
are here it's a few hundred kilometers
away and yeah so we have been existent
for thirteen years now I think but I'm
there for for 23 years and we are
responsible for data protection and for
Freedom of Information and also we do
the data protection stuff for the public
service and the private service which
means in Germany there are 18 colleagues
doing similar stuff and people for the
churches on for the broadcasting
companies Germany is a very complicated
area but now first of all what is data
protection everybody knows already
data protection is of course but
sometimes it's good to reflect what you
think you know then I talk about the
general data protection regulation then
about the more exciting stuff what to do
now with with what we have and have to
have a few conclusions or debates so
data protection is mainly about data
probably most people would agree or
although if this is on a slide probably
that's not true
it's not mainly about data but it's
about humans it's humans and their
rights their personality rights so it's
not the back up strategy right the
backup strategy is necessary but this is
not what data protection law is mainly
about and if we are thinking about
system design we want to approach the
very big questions as well
so are they effects on individuals and
what about effects on society in former
times
everybody knew okay there's a central
database and if there's a hacking attack
this may infringe some rights of people
but now we have a luring situation with
perhaps presidential elections that may
be influenced by social networks because
of data protection analysis of people so
something which is not really clear that
this is now part of our tasks as well
and of your tasks if you are developing
such systems of course everybody needs
to be a crypto expert otherwise we
cannot survive in the data protection
fields no not true
this is diffie-hellman but I'm not
telling about diffie-hellman crypto
functionality but about the perspective
this
these are Alice and Bob and the crypto
people are already over always so funny
and always poor Alice and poor Bob have
to communicate and the information
security perspective means that there's
an adversary in attica and that's Eve
for eavesdropping or Malory perhaps if
there is also some influence in on the
code perhaps so this is now where it's
totally
career the communication has to be
protected and they're very clever crypto
algorithms that help but from the data
protection perspective this is not
sufficient we think pop may be the
advisory as well so Ellis is telling her
life her secrets to Bob and everything
is protected on the communication way
and bob is misusing this information
this would be a data protection problem
if bob is an organization at least
because if it's only a fight between
individuals there we don't want to have
those cases there are some but usually
this is more a civil court thinking that
has to be also debated so the adversary
may be Bob and this means that data
processing as such is already a
potential interference with fundamental
rights this is not so bad
because also if you go to the doctor and
you you you you may have some impact on
your physical and your bodily privacy
because it's necessary to heal your your
disease or so so this is not something
which is untypical but we have to think
also about the organizations that may be
the adversaries in the data protection
field and that Ellis may have to get
help and this is a normal situation that
there are very powerful data processing
organizations so the DD PR is addressing
the very big ones as well as the very
small ones but especially the big ones
and we see that usually data protection
law is settled because of imbalance and
power because there are the very small
Alice's on the left hand side are also
small institutions we are by the way
also very small as the Data Protection
Commissioner but how to get the
information what is what is doing there
what is being done there so it's more
cloudy perhaps also blurred perspective
that nobody is really clear on what is
happening there and here the perspective
of
the individual should be supported
should be strengthened and there we come
with the general data protection
regulation people often attack me saying
what did you do there it's very bad it's
a whole sorry
we're the persons who have to take this
gdpr and we have to make sure that it's
enforced and we also in the beginning
wrote so many letters in what we would
like to see in the GDP are and some
parts are there and some are not and
some are different and so it's not my
GDP are still I'm not bashing the GDP
are I'm I have to work with that and I
just I try to derive the best things for
individuals for their data protection
and privacy from the GDP are and from
everything else what is now coming so
the main idea was one for all and all
for one this is of course a very old
idea and at least also in the Data
Protection Directive in Europe from 1995
so if we discuss Maria would SQL or
internet 1995 for a law on data
protection which is related to
information processing it's very very
old and they had the the idea of
harmonization all within Europe
everybody should have the same data
protection level good idea good for
companies good for everything which is
happening cross-border very good the
same level harmonization modernization
so this was the story of 1995 and it's
the same story now because 1995 did not
work so well there was the directive but
every country and especially Germany did
not transpose it in a correct way
everybody did something different which
is ok with this directive thing the
legal instrument now it's a change it's
a regulation and the regulation is
effective immediately and directly
unless there are opening clauses and
there are 70 opening clauses quite a lot
about 10 are mandatory the
optional and so the member-states still
have a say surely it's not possible to
have a harmonization within Europe or
other states in in such difficult topics
so it's really an abstract compromise
and now it has to be filled with life
so the gdpr is finished it's ready it's
there still if you read it you find that
you cannot understand everything or
perhaps only very few things because
it's very abstract and in this case it's
also abstract on purpose it's it's not a
buckets of feature because people tell
me it should least four it should last
for 20 30 40 years I I told you about
1995 it's so long ago but how is it
possible to have a legal norm that
exists for decades in the information
processing setting only if it is very
abstract and if refinement is done over
the time and we can all help by
progressing the state of the art for
example there are very many instruments
most of them are old so people are very
install now but usually the directive
had most of the instruments already but
what is new is the market location
principle and here it's not only
relevant for the Europeans in the room
but for everybody because even if a
company is not within Europe but
addressing European citizens or people
being in Europe perhaps by selling goods
or only by monitoring tracking people
users then they have to adhere to the
European law which is not very
astounding but in this case it's a new
thing we already have the first cases of
companies not being in the European
Union and now how to handle those cases
if there's not really the person that
there there has to be a person to
address okay but what about enforcement
responsibilities this is I think it's an
old thing people think it's a new thing
the controller is responsible so data
protection by design by default I will
tell about security is now also more
illegal base requirement then then
before which is okay but in my
perspective has had not had had not
worked well in the past data protection
impact assessment is about thinking
about the consequences and documenting
that and always because of the risks and
the risks are not the same as we have
learned from the IT and information
security sector it's not about only
confidentiality integrity availability
it's about the risks for the rights and
freedoms of natural persons so to give
an example for example the risk of
discrimination of being treated unfairly
of having a reputation damaged something
like that which is often very hard to
conquer in the real word certification
can play a role in the future and one
thing because and one is the reason one
thing is the reason because the media
took up the DDP are very very right I
think what were the finds very high
fines 20 million euros or 4% of the
company's income and this is for a big
companies good incentive not having this
big sanction so the sanction can be an
incentive and for the rest but it still
look quite mmm it makes make some well
impression and people often are very
afraid of our panicking and I think this
is this should not be done always it has
to be taken into account what is the
situation what do we have here and is it
possible to do already now the very best
very often it's not but let's go into
that direction and we will probably have
much necessity for negotiating among the
data protection
authorities and then everything again
will be challenged I had a case before
the European Court of Justice we have
now the seventh of eight year before we
go there it takes so long data
processing has has changed so so much at
the time so this is a solution which may
be the while the last word the last
answer if we have the European Court
decisions was but if it takes too long
it does not play a role okay all in all
I think it's a powerful tool box but it
can can be used also in the wrong way
and now it depends how to interpret it
how to make the cases and the cases are
there the data protection principles are
laid down in article 5 again they are
not very new still this is what you have
to argue that you have thought about it
the first one is like having a legal
baseline being having fair data
processing being transparent about what
is happening then this question of
purpose there's always a purpose of the
application of the service and by the
way a library library what is the
purpose of a library there very often is
a computer code it can be used for so
many different purposes so it's very
difficult for a developer to think
already it had what could be done are
they're very risky data treatments
processing procedures happening so this
is more difficult and therefore the
developers are hardly addressed in the
gdpr
but if the purpose is defined then the
data has to be limited for what is
necessary for the purpose so you may not
ask for the shoe size if you need the
financial data for example or the other
way around
data minimization is related to minimize
the the data to what is necessary the
correct height of the day the
correctness of the data is of course
important for everybody I think
storage limitation is
also about early deletion if you don't
need the data anymore erase them but if
often you have to keep them for other
purposes and the last one is on data
security the accountability is regulated
as well as you have to be able to prove
that you are compliant with the GD P R
and if I say you it's not the developers
it's those who are processing the data
but it's personal data this is always
the key questions because if it's not
personal then the GD P R does not apply
but very many data are personal data and
here they are broadly defined I think
again copy/paste from the older law but
sometimes in a different understanding
any information to that that is related
to subject a data subject that is
identified or identifiable and then we
see a little bit more on identifiability
it could be by a reference of to an
identifier and there you see for example
location data if I know location data
and the time then it's a direct spot if
it's it is really the granular
information then very often the
identifiability is there or online
identify us the IP address for example
and MAC addresses they are personal data
it does not mean that you may not work
with them but the GDP are at first
applies and then you have to check
whether the risk is treated the risks
are mitigated as far as necessary sorry
um there are six options for having a
legal ground a legal foundation and you
always have to find one so it's
different in America unless you have
specific laws you can do you can start
your computer usually and then later on
perhaps you have to check but here it's
about you have first to think what is
your legal basis your foundation three
of them are most mostly done and the
public service something which is not so
much related here perhaps the vital
interests or so but usually it's by
consent if the data are subject once
this service or once to disclose the
information wants to share the data this
has to be defined but by a contract if
there's some usual usage scenario or the
last one the legitimate interest and I
think those three are mostly now under
scrutiny because they can be used
whenever for for each situation and then
of course the argumentation will start
the negotiation is this now really a
legitimate interest and if it is their
overriding interest of the the data
subjects so this is something we saw at
the first day of GDP are that data
transfer was made possible there was
forbidden before because of legitimate
interest and I think this is there's
room for interpretation at least but
does not mean that it's not possible to
do data processing the rights of the
data subjects are strengthened I will
show you as a few pictures because it's
already too much text content is
something where it's a right of the
person to give consent but also be where
content is not so good as a basic
foundation for your data processing it
can be withdrawn with effect for the
future not for the past obviously but
still if you need the data then probably
you need a kind of contract some User
Agreement and not something where you
think the user should decide on its own
and can withdraw this content and so the
contract may be very often the better
solution but then it has to be clear
what is part of the contract for example
I paid for this good I receive this in
this this product but the newsletters of
subscription this can be on the basis of
a corner of consent and in the contract
contract write down what you want to do
with the data do you need them we are
here at a data conference for other
purposes do
need to derive to optimize your services
it's this part of the contract or should
it be based on consent the terms and
conditions obviously also play a role
and there's also European law in this
section where it's clear it must not be
something which cannot be expected so if
people have the feeling it's it's not
what what they thought it would be with
the data processing it can be a Twitter
shitstorm of course but it can also be
illegal right to information if you
collect data then you have to inform the
people if you collect it from other
sources you also have to inform them
unless they know that already so if you
buy databases and use the data on
persons then and they cannot know that
you have the data that's their right to
get the information directly so a push
you have to push the information usually
within one month there can be exceptions
then it's three months but usually one
month the other way it can be the
question the request of the data subject
I want to know what you have about me
this is the right to access it's it's
nothing new but many people did not know
about it and now many people are writing
letters or emails they want to know all
they know already that the data should
be deleted and now they want to check
whether they are really deleted or
whether they get this information with
the right to access and again within one
month time usually if this is possible
meaningful a development where where to
know where how do you know where the
data is or who can have perhaps copies
of of the data sets if it's not a
centralized approach it's not so easy so
it depends already on the design of the
enter code right - rectification I think
this is usually in the interest of
everybody everybody wants correct
addresses it must not be the case that I
want you to correct the data into
something wrong so this is not
rectification but
if the data set is wrong then it's
necessary to correct it so this is here
again within one month time right razor
the deletion sounds very effective
because then the data has to be gone if
it's a contract we had a financial
transaction are you allowed to delete
the information of the last receipt the
bills the invoices so tax law usually
prevents that so in Germany you can ask
for that of course but still it's
usually the the invoices have to be kept
for sometimes ten years sometimes even
longer and so they cannot be needed but
of course you must not as a controller
use this information then if the person
does not want that so they they have to
be archived in a way where they are not
part of the regular processing within
one month of course data portability
this is a new thing and it's not very
much related to data processing it's
more the idea of being able to switch
the providers to take one all your data
from one social network or one cloud to
put it into another cloud or social
network it should be handed to you or to
the other provider in a digital format a
machine-readable format and some people
argue and I think it can be all right
it's a PDF with OCR perhaps this might
may be sufficient well it's not meant
that way still it's a beginning because
very often if you take data from one
insurance and put it to another
insurance but they may not be compatible
what what they collected their main have
nothing new for the other side and the
the the way back so usually it depends
on how are the services on that level
developing or a smart car should I be
able to take my music taste and the seat
configuration from one hired car to the
other yes why not but are they really
compatible does it work that way
hmm so this is something we're probably
we will see the effect much later but
the first idea is and it has nothing to
do with data protection
it's not about deleting the data or
restricting something it's more about
being able to go to leave again the lock
in effect so it's an economic
infringement perhaps in some of the
business models that are existing within
one month by the way information about
logic involved this is interesting
because there's a recital the recitals
are the things explaining everything at
the beginning they are more valid
they're nothing but not as valid as the
deagle text and in the recital cities
each data processing with all the logic
behind so all the arable rhythms should
be made accessible to the users the data
subjects affected and then they add at
least four profiling ok so this probably
will mean that this information will
often not be disclosed and they had been
caught rulings in the last decades
because this is also an old idea and at
least in Germany our very big credit
scoring agencies they restricted the
access to this information because of
business secrets and the court said it's
a right to restrict this access so we
will see how it works but I think for
the future again if there are decisions
made perhaps on your professional life
on your health on your treatment on on
everything then perhaps it's very
necessary that some people get the
information or even you get the
information
have you been discriminated or not is it
a fair treatment or not to have the
possibilities to find out about it so
this is something which may be
interpreted differently now and better I
think in the future but then one month
the complaints can can come at every
second to our supervisory authorities
and they they are coming there are 10
times 20 times as much as before
and it's hardly possible to deal with
all the complaints some are very well
the pain in the ass only and some are
real some are really structural
deficiencies that have to be solved and
some are my neighbor has a wrong website
or so something like that okay but this
means we have to check and not not
within one month only if it's possible
so what about you which roles do you
play the definition of a controller is
that these are the ones processing the
personal data know they determining the
purposes and means of the processing the
decision they decide on what is
necessary what are we doing so those who
are well this is my business model I
want to use those data I want to use
them in this way then I'm the controller
those who are really treating the data
that can be the controller themselves
but it can be somebody on behalf of the
controller data center perhaps and this
is when the processor so they are not
that responsible on the determination of
the means because they get this
information they have to do that it's
like an order but of course it's also an
offer so usually it's a negotiation and
there's a contract the data subjects
whereas those whose data are processed
and then the producers of the products
services and applications they're not
mentioned in the real legal text but in
a recital and only in the sense of they
should be encouraged so I think most of
you are at least also a producers or a
developer some are props controllers or
work for controller summer processors
everybody is the data subject but the
obligations for the developers hmm no
there's no obligation so this is a short
talk no obligation of the gdpr on the
developers but of course if these
software tools should be used by
controllers so by those who want to use
some software or if your controller also
in another role then it has
course and important relevance to know
the GDP on and the design issue is also
really woven in into the design of the
GDP are themselves itself very the very
fraud that is the processing of personal
data should be designed to serve mankind
this is such a big sentence again from
1995 okay and it's not if the German
people here if you look at the German
translation you cannot find this
sentence it looks totally different
well but of course it's very good to be
an engineer because you serve mankind
it's clear right it's about the dreams
to come true and therefore we are right
in the spot of the GDP are let's take a
photo okay now we we come to this one
thing which is new and addressing data
protection by design it's only one
paragraph it's so abstract it's
everything and nothing and especially
its its targeting the controllers the
controllers they have an obligation to
do that ok fair enough the producers I
told you should be encouraged
how are you encouraged but I think by
giving you money probably so no not that
I can do that but no but that the
controllers asked for the service asked
for this criterion and use their
procurement system to say we want to
prefer this very good well-designed
product with data protection by design
this has to be preferred over the others
meaning you have those who who think
they are good at GDP our compliance may
have a better starting position the
controllers have not read very well but
we try to encourage them to encourage
you and also the states with their
funding schemes they could encourage
also very very good things or
sanitization initiatives if there's a
good sanitization that makes it so much
easier for the api's or so and can be
encouragement if there are tools for
only the infrastructure like open source
tools that help in software development
that are usable for everybody for free
for example encouragement so I think the
state and others they can do a lot more
than they think but nobody well hardly
anybody is reading that the data
protection by design means as usual
think of the full lifecycle start in the
beginning and at the end so think ahead
what is happening with with the all the
phases of data protection and one thing
is very well stress is the data
minimizing way how to be what really you
data are minimizing which is not so easy
and what is the starting seconds and the
starting setting should be maximal
maximum data protection friendly the
first paragraph and this is only a short
version year of data protection by
design is about first of all excuses
taking into account the state-of-the-art
the cost of so their first things okay I
look at the state-of-the-art I don't
find anything well so I don't have to do
it
not really but well if it's really not
available if nobody can think of a good
solution who should be then stressed or
demanded to do that the cost of
implementation similar may be there but
perhaps expensive the nature scope
context and purposes of processing okay
that is about if it's a risky data
processing decision-making by algorithms
or sensitive data such as medical data
for example or criminal data this is
something where it has to be done a
little bit more and usually it has
already done a little bit more and so
the risk of very varying likelihood and
so on they have to be taken into account
and then the controller those who are
not doing the development by themselves
they should make sure to implement the
appropriate technical and organizational
measures which are designed to implement
data protection principles this wasn't
the very beginning with the transparency
fairness data minimization storage
limitation purpose and so on it's
they are not so well defined that that
we can really have the metrics and the
checklist so that yes this is good this
is better and this is totally beyond or
so it's it's very difficult it's so
abstract but it does not mean that it
cannot be done and we are then looking
into the second paragraph this is the
default thing what is the default for
the data processing and then I go back
taking into account Dom this is a thing
that is in many paragraphs in twenty
four twenty five thirty two taking into
account thing first of them and write
down that you don't do something but it
was a default that's no excuse the
default has to be limited to what is
necessary which is not new it was
already in the data protection
principles but still it's something
where it must not be as a default
setting more data processing then really
required and to the amount of personal
data the extent of processing how are
they analyzed the period of storage and
accessibility and when I look at I think
of all data processing tools or services
then usually the default is set in
another way for example tracking I think
the default would be in no tracking
unless it's the purpose or personalized
recommendations if I want this service
like personalized medicine if I go to
the doctor and disclose nothing I don't
show you anything I don't tell you but
please treat me huh does not work but if
I want to buy a book why should the
information be automatically disclosed
or as a standard be disclosed about all
my interests probably not but if I'm I
want to get recommendations of course
it's possible
so this default thing means this is the
starting point and then because of
consent everybody can agree to do more
it's also the protection of children
many children no more see adults but um
protection of those who don't know and
then get
system and if they are asked they can
give more information this is very often
overlooked but think about it there's
there are no excuses here there should
be something which is perhaps also with
some economic idea behind similar to
this data portability where I told you
how to get data out of a system and put
them to the another system okay how do
we build them in so you've seen abstract
law they're less than one page how to
really do that it's a real gap between
the law and how to use it in practice
and we propose something and even long
before the gdpr which is still compliant
with what is there and we call it a data
protection model with protection goals
CIA is not the American Secret Service
here it's confidentiality integrity and
availability and everybody probably
knows in the room about what about
confidentiality integrity and a
variability here it's the data subjects
perspective but still most I think have
a feeling how to do with this
information for example do do you want
or have to protect the data that are
stored and now there are three more
protection goals and we use them to
since 2009 to discuss with developers
because they understood already CIA
those and we're used to think about the
adverse idea so how to attack
confidentiality is it something where
this really can be guaranteed how much
do I need if I if it's a broadcasting
view here of course it's not
confidential it's it's it should be
available right it's a different
different target but the others are
unlink ability at a landing ability
transparency and intervene ability
interesting words and they match the
data protection principles although they
have a different wording which is of
course not good but these are older than
the GDP are the unlink ability
protection goal means that domains have
to be set
and here you see the purpose again if I
collect data for the tax purpose
I must not use at least in Germany them
for other purposes the text system is
separated on purpose and for the purpose
and this is also if I disclose my data
to the doctor they must not give it to
my whatever what can I do my school for
example and there might be some
exceptions if it's really contagious or
so if I'm if it's a vital interest of
the school perhaps but usually it has to
be separated and therefore this is
something where we need to separate
processes storage media and think about
how to guarantee it sometimes it's also
about showing this is for a different
purpose you must not use it it's not so
good of course if it's not really
implemented ok transparency I think
everybody has an intuitive understanding
it's not about this transparency that is
happening or nobody knows it's the
transparency that everybody can know who
is interested in what is happening and
can understood can be reconstructed so
that the data processing can yeah if the
that also the risks can be mitigated
because people know about the risks and
what is happening and the intervene
ability this is an unusual word in most
disciplines which is better in fact than
the transparency word where everybody
has some intuitive feeling but different
ones and here it's about the data
subject rights to intervene in it Avene
if necessary
the first idea came when we had an
ambient intelligence system on people
who were monitored for the whole life
and because they were very old and they
could they could fall on the floor and
they needed help and so senses were all
over the place including in in their
beds and then we asked for how to
deactivate the sensors I want to go I
want to sleep in the bed but perhaps I
have some guests and I don't want this
organization to monitor what is
happening here no no you cannot do
activate the sensors yes ah but I want
to deactivate the sensors no no but then
we cannot rescue you anymore but this is
fair of course you cannot be they cannot
be liable for me if I deactivate the
sensors of course they cannot rescue me
but which is okay because they are
guests and they may rescue me um but
it's not possible and it was very
difficult first to find the the legal
basis basic in the law why is it
necessary to deactivate sensors and
there might be also some situations
where it's not possible but here it was
really necessary that they changed their
their system and therefore the intervene
ability was became clearer and clearer
that is necessary not to rely on
everything is coded and this is working
well and nobody can intervene but we
have to be able to stop and this may
change the conditions to be rescued to
be liable but the same with the the
automatic the autonomous cars when are
they on their own when do they put back
the responsibility to the driver this
has to be decided but something where
it's never possible that somebody can
intervene this is very creepy okay so we
had some some more work to be more
specific on the coding thing rushing
through that but again these protection
goals make sense also to think about new
technologies which are not well
reflected in any law but very often it
depends on the purposes and the legal
grounds then the risks that have to be
assessed
I told you they are also including
discrimination and other risks and
design patterns have been discussed with
our groups and Yaphank Houtman among
others and he did something which is
more the database view how to minimize
data and how to think about can you
minimize the data more can you delete
records or not get the de the data
records at home how to separate
them if necessary and of course for a
relational database that was mean that
it's not a possibility to join these
fields to be abstract to be more general
and for example blur the information
give only ranges of the age and not
nothing specific on the birth date for
example how to hide them how to
demonstrate your compliance how to
enforce that the system is running and
the communication with the data subject
on information and control this is not
only a nice picture it's also more
explained in a paper and some more
privacy patterns and there's even the
privacy patterns arc domain where people
can put on nice privacy patterns they
are categorized and may make sense to
look up those privacy patterns which
while I think everybody can participate
which means is a little bit well
this structure is not so clear but still
it's good to to understand what is what
is there already and other researchers
are now trying to a structure to make it
Khedira again but for example data
breach notification is demanded by the
gdpr
but how to make sure that you know about
a data breach and that you know that
it's really a data breach and that you
are quick enough enough to inform the
supervisor your authorities within at
max 72 hours and of course think about
the risks of the users for example if
they pass what is stole and what do they
have to do with financial data are
effective and we get we get for my small
area it's less than three million
inhabitants and trees we call Stein as
several data breach notifications every
day you know not not before the GDP are
there was few per months but now every
day several or invisible meter data are
often forgotten because they're
invisible
so you perhaps need to meter data but
should they be shared with others if the
users take the
photos their word files whatever why not
sanitize the information and there are
very small patterns being explained and
then it can be decided - if you want to
adopt them either the right way to go or
do don't they play a role so there is
already something done on the code
some people have published something
with specific gdpr
relevance but this mainly bird boils
down to you become more structured and
transparent and you know what is
happening yes you're already
professional you know everything but
perhaps to rethink what it has been done
and I have to admit we restructured our
data processing as well and found some
parts that could be optimized so what
was a healthy exercise to think again to
document and find out where we were good
and where we thought we were good but
we're not but of course now we have
better ok about division
something is here about if there's not
used functionality how to strip there
and so on of course there are some
dependencies that are very difficult
because we not nobody is having their
code probably only on their own but here
it's a small test from 2016 from
Republika who owns the website if you go
to a media website how many requests are
open from the browser of the user of
course on behalf of Bill Dior Spiegel or
some other newspapers or online
newspaper websites which means and they
proved it here in this talk there may be
a risk for example with the banners and
advertisement they put in some
children's for those because the banner
system is not very well checked for
security purposes similar if we see how
many companies are around and everybody
is doing or only a little bit but if
this is inherited by some code or
LinkedIn by some code and it's very
difficult to still be in control and now
we have a new court ruling from June on
Facebook fan
pages those who offer facebook fanpages
and are not Facebook themselves they are
still jointly responsible for the
incites program from Facebook so if
Facebook is not doing a good job because
they may not we don't know yet
apply the gdpr principles for their
insights or user analysis and the
facebook fanpage providers are joined
controllers and may also pay part of the
fines this now is under debate but
already decided so the debate is how to
work with this decision
meaning if you inherit code you have to
make sure is it now something dynamic
can you rely on something can you be
liable or has to be some something clear
that you cannot be liable that perhaps
the controller of course has to check
what is happening or other guarantees
that the professionality is improved so
this I think is a very big thing and
perhaps on the old ideas of what and how
much to implement Tim berners-lee said
because everybody said ah we should have
put more security into the World Wide
Web shouldn't we and he said no he said
perhaps not because at that point it was
more important to get out to to be
visible and not to put in security
already perhaps we haven't fill it
wouldn't have finished then then serve
this disagreed said he regretted and not
building in more security features in
the basic internet protocols but I
understand both positions of course now
we are much well we have learned from
history I would say perhaps we are not
collect more clever but um I see with
for example IOT the same mistakes are
repeated that we know already there we
know the solutions of an industry
support for cars the same mistakes are
repeated why now we we of course have a
better starting position than
Tim berners-lee okay so now I cannot
understand that it's not better
installed by default and now I'm talking
about security okay
the conclusions are we are still missing
of a few puzzle pieces there are some
initiatives to collect them like the
privacy patterns or this European data
protection initiative IPAN you can check
out the webpage I will provide the
slides of course building in security
we are not there this has failed so this
is something where I I'm quite
astonished that we haven't seen more
progress building in data protection is
even less developed so it's you are all
pioneers if you join me and working on
this feat in this field and we have to
take the focus to the perspective of the
individuals and I think it's very
necessary because we depend so much more
on computer systems on data processing
and this means it's not only demanded by
the GDP are to implement data protection
in the data processing system not on
technology or also processes
organization and so on and I'm pretty
sure it will be much more demanded by
controllers they have to demand it and
it's also good if they demand it because
those who are then better off they can
prove that the state-of-the-art can be
better that they have a better position
in this hopefully level playing field
and that also the small ones now this is
a very optimistic view from from my side
but can concur with the bigger bigger
companies that are still trying to
reinterpret the GDP are and not doing
the real stuff on building in some
guarantees for security and data
protection but if there are good
solutions they have to be made visible
otherwise the Supervisory authorities
wouldn't know that the state-of-the-art
has enhanced and therefore there's no
excuse anymore to have a worse solution
and this is now something where I not
we like to see your questions but your
output and that perhaps over the next
five years we get a so good repository
of code of concepts that can be used
also to show it is possible to implement
much more in the gdpr than before and
for the new systems like algorithms and
deciding on some big data tools or
autonomous IOT whatever things I think
we are really asking for good solutions
otherwise it's much too risky thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much married we're gonna
take three questions in the room now and
then we'll go up let's start with a very
determined guy in green first of all
thank you for the talk it's great to see
data protection and in this kind of
conference as well I was going to ask
kind of an open question about the
rights to to deletion but I'm guessing
that that will always be the answer it
depends so instead I'll go for a really
specific scenario lots of people here
are probably building algorithms of some
sort some of which have memory right
it's quite a specific question
deliberately so let's say that in some
of these algorithms there are
identifiers that can identify a person
uniquely so someone is a doctor is 27
and is from a small village then that's
enough to I'd assume we identify them if
that person asks for a deletion sum it's
easy to erase a couple of CSVs but the
model can still rebuild that information
because it was trained on it and it has
memory does that imply and I am trying
to get to something that's a yes or no
answer that that model needs to now be
retrained and that it can no longer
exist or if that's not very educated
question there's a paper punch Matic
often others from 2017 working on how
much does that framing reveal on
individuals so even if the doctor has
not asked for deletion is it clear from
the training material which is only from
the structure now learned by the
algorithm already clear that he was part
in this scenery so it's even one one
step further and then the deletion
obviously would not be sufficient this
is not decided on the level of the gdpr
and there's also another thing of
artificial or sophisticated so generated
fires if you take for example our
demographic information here and we are
building totally different datasets are
they personal data so they have never
been part of anything but because it's
only statistic information but we we
mimic something in a different data set
that is equivalent enough perhaps and so
I think this this can be anonymous data
because there are no really
persons behind but now if a person comes
into the room and the demographic
statistics change and so similar to your
question how to put that in the other
data set as well so i'm i know a few
computer scientists who think about it i
know no lawyer right now thinking about
that and it would not be directly
applicable that this information has to
be needed deleted and also because what
was the reason why this doctor was
already in the data set if he agreed to
that like consent or contract or
whatever then it's only to be deleted
for the future the effect for the future
of course it was something where it has
to be corrected because he put in false
information and now this algorithm is
working wrongly for for so many people
then it's the interest of everybody to
correct that of course but there are
other parts and if this information now
the last thing for the very specialist
here if this information is not directly
visible in because there's no personal
direct personal information it can be
that he influenced the data set but it's
not clear what to change so you have you
offered now to rebuild your training but
perhaps you have a trained thing and how
to remove it then we have article 11 and
this is that specific rights won't apply
if it's not possible and that the
individual can be identified this is
under estimate so not many people know
article 11 it's not understood it's in
fact it's about blurring by cookies for
example if we we have a cookie that may
be shared by other people i disclose my
cookie information then the provider can
say I won't give you information because
I'm not sure about that and this means
probably no need to rebuild but the risk
may need some other treat because of
this it may be some other treatments
that have less to do with the Data
Protection Directive or regulation here
but it's a very interest if you're
writing papers on that and I'd like to
read them no because it's really not
just cast yet not many people have
understood this very specific problem
yeah so I wanted to challenge a bit your
stance on gdpr
maybe you heard Peter Till from Palantir
he said gdpr is basically hampering
startups because they didn't have enough
resources to build all of this
complexity in and I personally saw like
smaller websites or services simply
shutting down because they just don't
have the money to implement GPR
compliance and it's also another problem
we've heard about just like smaller
communities like interest clubs and they
also save data about their members and
like who should do that like they don't
have an IT specialist who would like
create some secure storage for that and
therefore as my first sentence was I did
not write the gdpr this is indeed indeed
a thing that could have been solved in a
different way but now we have it here in
that way I think the hope of the makers
of the gdpr
was that the setting when it applies
because we know the the text for more
than two years now that that the normal
setting is already solved so why don't
we have the standard tools that protect
the data of small associations or why
don't we have the libraries that already
implement what is there that the
startups have better starting points
it's not an answer for everything it can
be very innovative that it's not simply
simply not possible that something has
already been solved but all this
documentation exercise it is not about
everybody should reinvent the wheel but
rely on a stable foundation and this is
missing and this is now the problem and
therefore when this transition period
has not been used in a good way and now
I hope that it will be used now because
we get thousands of requests from
associations and small companies and so
and we start every we have own debates
and workshops with startups we want
innovation we want clever information
but we need also a reliable foundation
and this has not be
we are we developed before in developed